[Music]
all right so there's a bunch of uh
google employees who were requesting
that google give them a significant pay
bump because of inflation like the way
that their money is being spent right
now
um like the way that all of our money is
being spent are not being being
printed right um it's reducing your
power when you're buying something i get
that concern because there's a lot of
people that read that and then they're
like holy [ __ ]
if my like 60 grand
is only going to be able to afford 40
grand with the stuff don't i need to get
paid more yeah so google um you know
heard these employees
and then they were like that's very
interesting that you guys want to pay
increase because of inflation but um
we're sorry we're not we're unable to do
that at this time what's a complicated
issue and then they proceeded to give
uh
a bunch of their top executives
they wanted one million dollars each
raising their salaries from six hundred
and fifty thousand to one these
billionaires need to start paying their
fair share there it is
start [ __ ] paying their [ __ ] fare
but without the billionaires who are
gonna provide the jobs this is pretty
good that's true
they need to stop taxing all of the
people stop talking all right
that's why i think we should burn these
buildings down wait what
if i didn't say that i have heard him
say it let's burn down the big
corporations holy [ __ ] so yeah it's it's
volatility it's for their top execs
right they're they're going to be
jumping making the jump to 1 million
from 650 000
um
there's a chief financial officer senior
vice president senior another senior
vice president and a chief business
officer and a president of global
affairs that's crazy you know what this
reminds me of um remember when we had
the recession and then people were
talking about the bailouts right and
then how the bailouts were going to help
the companies and and the economy and
then right after the bailout happened
like i think it was a aig or the
insurance company
they celebrated by going on a all paid
vacation for all the executives like
bought a hotel out yeah they got raises
so
um
that's
taxpayer money that's not because they
made money from the business or whatever
you know i wish there was like an
economist
that could explain
what like
what the purpose is because like all i
hear is the reason why you need to bail
out those companies is if they crash
then everyone's going to wipe their ass
with hundred dollar bills right i'm like
okay cool i get that concept
but if you need a lot of faith for
someone that's on the [ __ ] end of the
stick to go oh okay that's why they need
the money and not me yeah exactly right
so i'm like i wish someone could explain
it and then also on the other end don't
[ __ ] go and celebrate on private jets
and [ __ ] well they did
less than a week after the federal
government committed 85 billion to bail
aig executives of the aig
insurance company headed for a week-long
retreat at luxury resort and spa the
saint regis resort in monarch beach
california yeah what if they used their
points though i think they did
they did oh sorry what if they used
their points
they used their credit card points they
had really good rewards those guys get
really good like frequent flyer models
tax payer frequent flyer miles they also
just got 85 billion dollars to bail them
out so like you can afford it and they
get all like access to all the cool
lounges in the airport so plus i want to
wipe my ass with 100 bills that sounds
fun it feels abrasive abrasive is a good
word yeah i probably shouldn't do that
to the google i guess the google
employees their starting salary is
already pretty high too though
where they start at well i mean a lot of
them are like 200 300 g's for sure so
they don't need more money i mean they
everyone does wait wait that was the
wrong hat
they don't get paid enough they don't
need more money i want to know the math
though so like for example you said like
what five execs went from like 650 000
to like a million there's four four of
them yeah right so that's a 350 thousand
dollar race times 12 to a million 12
four that's 14 that's 1.4 million
dollars in raises right um in total so
how many and wait four execs are yeah
exactly yep good how many employees
you know what i mean were like they have
400 people yeah like 1.4 million that
they could have dispersed they gave it
to four people versus thinking let's
take care of more people because at 1.4
if they if they gave it to the company
it might be a 25 raise for everyone
like depending on how many people they
employ well depends on who's asking for
a raise you know based off of inflation
but does it also work like that because
i saw a meme and it was like lebron
james and uh i think steph curry theirs
or someone else their net worth is worth
than all of the wnba's pay oh
so like does money just
move can you move it or is it worth like
that you know or i got which hat you're
wearing right now when you're talking
about this yeah i got a mega question
all right
i got a mega question that's true that's
one or more uh business question okay so
like let's say um
is a company
responsible
for what the government inflates so like
the money supply was inflated by the
government right right and then so to
adjust for the inflation do companies
have to adjust or
like whose fault is you need a tesla for
that one that's a good one that's good
maybe maybe this is i don't know that
was a good joke that's a good question i
think i think it's different because of
like things like the consumer price
index right um regardless if they go
what does that mean [ __ ] smart [ __ ]
yeah dude something about like this if
uh if i'm the company right and then
inflation happens
do i have to pay my employees more
because of inflation technically no but
am i also if i'm selling a product am i
charging more because of inflation
therefore bringing in more money yeah
because then it's like if i'm charging
more i'm bringing more money but i'm not
paying out in order to like you know
balance but on the other side their cost
might be more too like if you're a water
company right you are charging more on
water because your water source is
charging you more yeah i mean that's
what happens right when they do tariffs
even like they just pass it on to the
consumer and they go cool we're hiking
the prices on your goods like there's a
lumber shortage right now right so a lot
of contractors aren't getting paid more
but their costs are more because the
lumber is more expensive so then when
you know you're building someone you
might get the bill and go why the [ __ ]
is it a hundred thousand dollars more
but it doesn't the the guys that are
building the house don't get that extra
money yeah so they charge more but
technically their net profit is the same
as before that's why economics is so
hard it's easier to just say slogans tax
the rich eat the rich there you go they
say eat the rich yeah they eat the
original yeah eat the rice more of a
burning thing yeah wait yeah this maybe
yeah that's true
i needed a burning hat that's corporate
democrats yeah just turn it to the
hip-hop bite and then you'll be okay
hip-hop item or you can get two with the
two gloves right
oh yeah
yeah lacrosse i don't know man the whole
inflation thing is really really
complicated though you know like [ __ ]
yeah man i feel like we're all in the
same place too right even as a company
it's kind of just like you need to make
more money today in order to live the
same way but if you don't get paid more
money then your your options change you
have to like start looking at other
things and thinking about other things
you know what i mean so i think it all
kind of like continues to trickle down
right
but at least everyone's getting raises
at the same time
that's for decades that's been going on
it's been keeping up with the rate of
inflation really well inflation is you
[ __ ] feel it this year right yeah you
like really how do we protect ourselves
from inflation like every meal you go
out crypto [ __ ] it's difficult thousand
percent crypto you just deflate a little
that's the right answer there's a work
called hedging that's like
basically if you know that inflation's
coming then you buy things
before that happens of value so that's
why real estate was going crazy because
the interest rate was low meaning like
the mortgage percentage was low so then
um
you know it incentivized people to buy
homes and and you know they wanted to
stimulate the economy while things were
still not moving in the economy versify
their like their portfolio during the
pandemic the
economy wasn't really moving so but
people were buying stocks because of
stimulus checks and all these other
things and ballers they remember the uh
recession so they they saved up actual
cash and then so they were waiting on
the sidelines for a crash to happen with
all that stuff and they were like i'm
gonna buy when it's time that never came
so that's why when things started going
like oh low interest rate i'm gonna buy
homes i'm gonna buy this they actually
had cash this time to buy a bunch of
things and then so the rich got richer
during the pandemic because they had
money to play with so like if you had a
little bit of money to go into crypto or
whatever um you actually if you bought
the right coins you did well but if you
were like me you lost everything but
like that's basically how people stay
rich or or build wealth is like you you
want to try to predict what's gonna
happen and you're like oh [ __ ] the
dollar is gonna go down in value well i
better put it into something like a home
which will add value or crypto or maybe
even stocks yeah and then that's kind of
what we've been seeing and then the
people that don't know and have no
financial i guess like iq they're kind
of left in the in the dust you know yeah
the interest rates are still low right
now it's under three four homes yeah
yeah how long do you think that's going
to last for i don't know they say
they're gonna pump it this year just
announced that they're gonna pump it up
that's where everything slid a few more
points yeah it sucks because that's i
think at the end of the day like when
you're the littlest guy in that
conversation with the least financial iq
and then you start shouting the ladders
you get eliminated first
i highly believe that like what happened
with the with the car wash you guys know
what happened with the car washers union
they tried to do no so back in the day
there was like all these like people
when they were doing hand car wash and
everything they tried to start a union
to be like let's all get paid the same
and then they turn into automated car
wash turn into automated car washes
that's what sucks man i think a good
society makes the quality of life for
the average and poorest people better
each time because it's so hard to find
the answer to inflation but it's easier
to find the answer to car wash guys that
all want to get paid right or even like
yeah comparatively that's an easier
solution walk up to the kiosk and we'll
make the burger with robots [ __ ] you and
it seems [ __ ] up and we'll make less
mistakes which is crazy because they
don't come high to the workplace
not yet i mean from a macro perspective
though that's like progressive
you know what i mean people losing out
on jobs and stuff people are losing out
on jobs and stuff dude
honestly the [ __ ] new car wait that's
actually both hats people losing out on
jobs you don't like them
are significantly better than the
[ __ ]
machine way better machine car washes
[ __ ] up my paint and i bet that [ __ ] is
expensive for them to fix it i don't
mind going up to the little machine
kiosk at mcdonald's instead of getting
it ordered from the person i agree yeah
but i like both so i think automation
helps a lot but what what about when
you're in the drive-through there's no
kiosk i'm not i sold my car for crypto
dude i can't even get a car wash or
nothing [ __ ] and you made the right
moves because that car made you a
million dollars
[Laughter]
here you go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you